في السعوديه اعلنت هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء
والتقنيه عن انضمام 10 شركات عالميه
ومحليه للبيئه التنظيميه التجريبيه
للتقنيه الناشئه وذلك بهدف خلق بيئه مرنه
ومحفزه لمقدمه الخدمات والحلول والمنتجات
المبنيه على التقنيات الناشئه وللمساهمه
ايضا في جذب الاستثمارات العالميه
والتعزيز لاستثمارات المحليه عبر ابتكاري
حلول وخدمات في بيئه تجريبيه ذات تنظيمات
مارينا
[موسيقى]
الضميري نفسك فيديوهاتنا من الرياض مستشار
تقنيه المعلومات في هيئه الاتصالات
والفضاء والتقنيه الدكتور عبد العزيز
البدري حياك الله دكتور اهلا وسهلا فيك
معنا
انضمام هذه العشرات
وليش انضمت في هذا التوقيت
السعوديه
الانظمه التجريبيه في السعوديه طبعا في
البدايه شكرا لكم على هذه الاستضافه
المفهوم البيئه التنظيميه التجريبيه
والساند بوكس
اتى لبحث سبل رفع نقطه تنظيمي لدى المنظم
القطاع وايضا في نفس الوقت رفع همم
الابتكاري والتقني لدى الشركات الواعده
والعقول المبتكره همم
منذ اطلاق او الاعلان عن البيئه تنظيم
التجريبيه البيئه التنظيميه تجريبيه
لتقنيه الناشئه
تقدموا عدد من الشركات همم فوق التوقعات
وقبلنا 10 همم بنسبه قبول 21% تقريبا همم
يعملون في مختلف همم الصناعات في قطاع
الطاقه في قطاع الصحه والاتصالات وايضا
صناعه همم مجمل العشر شركات همم عندهم همم
يعني براعه تقنيه في مجالات تقنيه محدده
مثلا الاشياء البلوكشن الحواس بالسحابيه
همم الذكاء الاصطناعي واخيرا تقنيات
الواقع المعزز والافتراضيه مش اهم الشركات
هذه طبعا ولله الحمد والمنه همم واللي
جاذبيه السوق همم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والوجود العقول النيره تقدمت
للبيئه عده شركات محليه واجنبيه من
ابرازها مايكروسوفت سيمز همم وغيرها من
الشركات اللي همم فعلا لا اثبتت اهميه
وجود هذه الادوات التنظيميه لدى المنظم
القطاعيه ليش تهتم هذه الشركات اليوم
بالسوق السعودي او بالتنظيميه
للشركات
موجوده ما كان في شيء منحه سابقا لكن احنا
اليوم نعيش ثوره همم يعني في النضج
التنظيمي هائله جدا وايضا جاذبيه السوق
اصبحت اكثر شهيه لدى
المستثمرين سواء المحليين او الاجانب همم
[موسيقى]
بيئه تنظيميه التجريبيه هي احد همم
الادوات لجذب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه همم
لانه عندنا وقت يعني عندنا الايدي الماهره
عندنا العقول النيره وعندنا نضج التنظيمي
القطاعي في مختلف القطاعات الذي يساهم في
همم يعني رفع من جاذبيه السوق بالاضافه
الى رؤيه السعوديه 2030 التي اوضحت ووضعت
نور ستار او ال- يعني النجم الشمال
للمملكه في هذا الجانب طيب ما الذي سيتغير
يعني بعد همم انضمامها هذه همم الشركات
عملها في مجال همم يعني
بالتنظيميه والتجريبيه في المملكه شيء
الكثير طبعا احنا نتكلم عن اول قطره همم
القادم اجمل واكبر هناك ان اعتقد شقين همم
لهذا السؤال في الفوائد قريبه المدعو فيه
الفوائد بعيده المدى قريبه المدى نضج
التنظيمي لدى هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء
والتقنيه همم معرفه الادوات التنظيميه
المناسبه لكل تقنيه ولكل همم يعني حاله
استخدام همم عندنا احنا مفهوم نؤمن فيه
هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه الابتكار
ثم التنظيم احنا نعرف عالميه انا يعني
العالم يعرف انه تنظيم
فهو يقتل السوق قبل ما يبدا فاحنا العكس
احنا نروح للشركات نشجعهم نقول لهم احنا
نقول نتعلم معكم نبغى نعرف كيف ننظم وبنفس
الوقت كيف يمكن ونحفز ونجذب الاستثمارات
لكم انتم همم يعني على سبيل المثال همم
حجم
الاموال او ال ال ال
الاستثمارات التي وصلت وجمعت من الشركات
الناشئه كنا نتوقع انها يصل الى واحد
مليار ريال في هذه السنه في النصف الاول
تجاوز 2.1 همم مليار ريال ريال همم وهذا
اكثر من يعني الرقم المتوقع جدا همم يعني
هذا هو النضج التنظيم اللي احنا اما فوائد
يعني المدى البعيد فنطن حديث باذن الله
همم خلقه وظائف نوعيه همم يعني عديده
بالاضافه الى اسهامات همم ايجابيه في
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي برده مش اهم هذه
الوظائف
اليوم همم طبعا احنا بنتكلم على نوعين من
الوظائف في وظائف تقنيه بحته لها نيش معين
لها طابع تقني همم مختص همم في مجال معين
مثل كلاوتك همم من النادر انك تحصل احد
مختص في الكلاود بيحدثه او في تقنيات
الكلاوتك كمبيوتر
ونفس الكلام ينطبق على الانترنت اشياء
والبروكين والذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم نشهد
نموذج عالمي اا من يعني من نماذج الذكاء
الاصطناعي
نتعامل معها اليوم همم وصلت بقدرتين
القدره الحاسوبيه والقدره البشريه وهذا ما
نطنحلها باذن الله في هذا الوطن الشركات
ممكن تستفيد يعني همم ما تحدثنا عن تقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي الامور يعني التقنيه
اللي تذكرتها يعني هل ممكن نلحظ تغير في
طبيعه عملها طبيعه الابتكارات المقدمه في
خاصه انه التقنيه اليوم يعني اصبحت تساهم
في كثير من الصناعات الكثير من شئون
الحياه المختلفه يعني طبعا بلا شك التقنيه
هي حجر الزاويه
لنمو جميع القطاعات نتكلم عن الصناعه
الصحه الاتصالات وغيرها من الانقطاعات همم
الممكنه الاساسي هي التقنيه همم
باذن الله سنههد من خلال هذه البيئه همم
يعني همم يعني اضافات نوعيه لم نكن نشهدها
من القبل لان البيئه تمنح مساحه امنه همم
معفيه من بعض التنظيمات وبوجود بعض
الحوافز لعمل الابتكارات والتاكد من هذا
النموذج هو قابل همم او مناسب ومنائم
للسوق والشريحه المستهدفه واحنا يعني نطمح
باذن الله من هذه الدنيا ان نعجل من
تماركته بما يسمى وقت الوصول الى السوق من
البذره الفكره حتى وجود المنتج ده العميل
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يبارك فيك دكتور
عبد العزيز مستشار تقنيه المعلومات في
هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه